JEFF POSNICK: Hi, everybody.
Welcome to this week's episode
of "YouTube Developers Live."
And this week I have a special
guest, folks behind FanBridge.
Local with me, I'm Jeff Posnick
in New York, we have
Noah and Spencer who
are more on the
business side of FanBridge.
And they're going to talk a lot
about the background of
the company.
And we have some of the
developers who have been
building FanBridge powered by
some of our YouTube APIs,
Gabriel and Jonathan joining us
via Hangout from Argentina.
So thanks very much for
doing that, guys.
And yeah.
Let's actually just get right
into it because there might be
some folks out there who
aren't sure what
FanBridge is all about.
So if you guys can go into a
little bit more detail, I
would be real interested
in hearing.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Yeah, I
mean, so Noah and I, we
co-founded FanBridge about
five years ago.
We were graduating from the
Stern School of Business
together, kind of entering
a full-time day jobs.
So believe it or not, the
first couple of years of
FanBridge, this was a nights
and weekend project.
So midnight till 4:00 in the
morning and then all day
Saturday, Sunday.
JEFF POSNICK: Gotcha.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: And what
we were trying to think
through is how could we address
the fact that we saw
kind of inefficiency in how this
proliferation of content
creators were building audience
in a sustainable way
around that content creation.
So we saw more of them coming to
market than ever before in
more verticals than
ever before.
And at the same time, kind of
the technology around them in
terms of building audience
was lacking.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: So we
developed that out and Gabriel
and Jonie down in Buenos Aires
were the first two people we
brought on full time.
So then the four of us just
kind of went from there.
JEFF POSNICK: Great.
And I'm sure that kind of the
rise of YouTube as a platform
creator has kind of coincided
with some of your business
plans around that.
SPENCER RICHARDSON:
Absolutely.
JEFF POSNICK: It's great to see
everybody building on top
of YouTube as a platform and
making things possible for
creators to get the word out
about their content.
So who exactly is the target
audience for the types of
services that you
guys provide?
NOAH DINKIN: Yeah, definitely.
So we worked with other
different types of content
creators when we first started
so musicians, athletes,
authors, anybody who makes
different kinds of content.
And then really over the last
year, we noticed a couple
things happening, one that video
content specifically
YouTube videos, became the
number one most engaged with
content type across the
entire platform.
So through email and social
media, it was the number one
piece of content that
people would click
on and engage with.
Right?
So that was really
interesting.
JEFF POSNICK: Versus what
other types of--
SPENCER RICHARDSON:
Like photo, text.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: So the
numbers we were looking at
were like click-through rates
and email campaigns, or
engagement with social media
modules, and Facebook pages,
as well as where inbound traffic
for audiences were
coming from.
NOAH DINKIN: So that was
really interesting.
And then as we dug in more to
the YouTube ecosystem, we
realized it's massive.
And you guys think it's funny
because you've been here for a
while, but it was just eye
opening to us how big this
world was and how many different
creators there are,
both individual guys in their
home making videos with tiny
audiences that are growing,
individual guys with massive
audiences, the funded channel
initiative where Google
committed hundreds of millions
of dollars to
fund original content.
You have the MCNs sitting on
hundreds or thousands of
channels sometimes tens
of thousands.
And then more and more in 2013,
you're seeing brands
really deciding that YouTube is
a place they need to have a
presence where they
did with other
platforms a few years ago.
And so today, our platform
really serves best people who
are content creators that
have an audience.
So that's the individual
creators, the funded channels,
the MCNs, all these guys who are
attracting tens, hundreds,
or millions of fans.
And we're giving them tools to
help their audience come back
over and over again.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: And just to
add to that, big thing that
we're looking at is, these
guys are taking a more
traditional business
perspective now.
So they're looking to build a
business around that content.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: And so I
think that's really the core
of the infrastructure that we're
developing is how do you
create a recurring kind of
revenue or a recurring
engagement stream so that way
we can maximize kind of the
lifetime value of
that audience.
And that really is, I think,
where the core of what we
started building fits well
with kind of the YouTube
ecosystem is the fact these guys
are getting monetized and
they're looking for new ways
to monetize as well that we
can support.
JEFF POSNICK: Excellent.
So anybody out there who already
has an established
audience of some size might
find some value from using
FanBridge basically.
SPENCER RICHARDSON:
Well, yeah.
And we do have, it's interesting
because there's a
certain high-growth vertical as
well that they start very
small, and they grow
very quick.
So I think while the core
technology operates best for
people with kind of developing
current audience, at the same
time, we are seeing particularly
as we talk and
work with like a multi-channel
networks, part of the thinking
there is, how do we also
leverage the benefit of the
audience growth from kind of the
incumbent players and help
that leverage new people coming
in to those networks.
That way we, can scale them up
faster than what might happen
kind of organically on the
platform at present.
JEFF POSNICK: Awesome.
So I know that you guys are
integrating with a number of
different APIs, but before we
get into the more technical
discussion, be great to see a
demo of what the platform
looks like from the perspective
of somebody who's
using FanBridge, and I believe
we're going to be handing that
over to the folks in Argentina
to drive that demo.
GABRIEL SOSA: All right.
So I'm going to do a Screen
Share now so you can look.
JEFF POSNICK: Very good.
So that's coming through fine.
Thanks so much.
GABRIEL SOSA: Oops.
Sorry guys.
JEFF POSNICK: No worries.
GABRIEL SOSA: So what we got and
you see here actually, is
the main page where once
a user logs in.
And you have here the
activity feed.
And of course, open through
the YouTube API, we are
getting information about all
the videos once the user
connect with us, their
user account.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
So users go through the like
OAuth to login flow, and they
grant access to their account.
And then you're able to make
these calls on their behalf?
GABRIEL SOSA: Right.
Exactly.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
GABRIEL SOSA: So on top of that,
what we do is gather
information of all videos and
also using the v2 API, which
is the last release of the API,
what we do is to start
persisting and saving the
watch time, which is an
important metric for our
users right now.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
GABRIEL SOSA: So here, what you
can see is amount of, in
this case, the amount of bang
that YouTube drive has drive
to each video or the channel
in this case for this user.
Right?
JEFF POSNICK: And that's
obviously very useful
information I mean--
GABRIEL SOSA: But basically,
right now, you can imagine
that content creators
are looking for.
JEFF POSNICK: And I think that's
a recent change where
people kind of realize that
views might not be as
meaningful as actual
minutes watched.
And we do expose in the API ways
of running reports and
getting them to watch
details now.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: And one
thing I would just add in the
dashboard, is the fact that a
big question we were getting
from people is, how are the
marketing efforts I'm doing
across email, across social
media, across mobile having a
direct impact on the watch
time of my videos?
And so we're actually, the first
marketing platform to
have launched an ability through
the watch time API to
see exactly how much your email
campaigns in each of
those channels, social media,
and so forth, are actually
driving down to a video level
as well as an aggregate.
So it's not just showing kind of
an overlay of your historic
watch time across all videos.
It's really about how are
marketing efforts and actions
you're taking in the FanBridge
platform directly contributing
to your number one metric.
JEFF POSNICK: Great.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: And in the
activity feed, the concept
there, I'll just add to Gabriel,
is really tied into
more of a recommendation
engine.
So the idea is turning an
account holder, so a digital
marketer, or a DIY kind of
person into basically giving
them a to-do list now of actions
that we know based on
the global system.
And the data on the back end
is what they need to do to
impact that watch time metric.
So we're making them more
focused kind of marketers,
which is also saving
them time.
And time is probably the hidden
commodity that's the
most valuable to all of these
guys is what we're noticing.
JEFF POSNICK: I mean, a lot of
this information has been
available in the past, but just
via web interfaces like
off of YouTube.com.
We just haven't had an API
for a lot of these
things up until recently.
So I really do think that it's
not necessarily that you
couldn't get this information
before.
It's just presenting it in a
compelling way that saves
time, and it's great to hear
that you guys are like using
it for actionable things
that you could do.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Exactly.
Well tying it into their
marketing efforts directly
hasn't been done.
I think that's the unique, kind
of the key is, I want to
know what I'm doing on Facebook,
or I'm doing within
YouTube, or I'm doing through
email is having an impact.
And I think being able to answer
that is pretty cool.
JEFF POSNICK: Awesome.
Was there anything else
on the interface that
you wanted to show?
SPENCER RICHARDSON:
Definitely.
JEFF POSNICK: Cool.
If we switch back to that,
and you guys can drive.
GABRIEL SOSA: Sure.
So I want to spend time
with this page.
So apart from the total
gain time, we
have total watch time.
We are starting in
a live feed.
That is where you're looking
here, all the videos.
And also we view how much time
that's viewed in the last
minutes and some recommended
actions.
For example, one of these
actions is, OK, you have 7,000
views, 6 comments.
Why don't you create a widget
so you can add more views on
that video.
For example, I'm going
to paste here
one of our own videos.
And with this, we created-- this
is a widget where we have
two options or two
gaining options.
One is to watch the whole
video, you have
to update the email.
So this is a way to subscribe
to the FanBridge list.
Or in the last week, we added a
new feature that is you have
to subscribe to the
YouTube channel.
I think this is great for the
YouTube creators because it's
going to basically boost
they're channel, right?
So I would just add options
where everyone can see.
Also, we can set up how long we
want to allow people to see
the video with muted, so
we don't have that.
How long we want to allow the
people to watch the video
before asking to subscribe to
that, I would put 50 seconds
to ask for subscription.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
And this using the standard
play rate API methods or
during start time
and end time?
GABRIEL SOSA: This is-- right.
This is all using the standard
script editor, but we added
some subscript code
outside new layer.
And so it's rescinded.
And it's all using the v2 API
and the Google API to
subscribe people to
their channels.
So with this, say we create
the embedded code.
And with this, we have both, a
subscript code that people can
paste in their own site, or we
are giving them a direct
landing page so they can put in
an iFrame within their site
or just give it to everyone.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
Great.
GABRIEL SOSA: So I will
paste this here.
Everybody, it's only 50/50.
JEFF POSNICK: Epic
ping pong match.
GABRIEL SOSA: And there it asks
you to subscribe to the
channel so you can continue
watching the video.
JEFF POSNICK: Gotcha.
GABRIEL SOSA: So yes.
Basically, this is a great way
for us to allow creators to
promote their own videos now and
also to getting people to
their own list.
And of course, this empower more
activity feed in a way
that everyone who is starting
getting into their own list,
we are going to show with them
live in this activity feed.
So it's all inter-rated.
JEFF POSNICK: Great.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: I think
the interesting thing also
just to add, so we did quite a
bit of testing around this
stuff before we launched
production, so we'll bring in
different channels just in the
office sometimes and have them
work through.
And one thing we noticed is by
having that timing gate giving
people the ability to kind of
have a lead-in teaser, we were
able to actually almost double
the conversion rate that we
were seeing.
So typically, you kind of find
that right moment when we've
all seen on TV where they cut
to commercial right at that
like terrible kind of moment.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
So I wanted to see what
was going to happen
with ping pong match.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Exactly.
So who won?
Or did the shot make it
to the table or not.
So that actually, is something
that just an example of how
the data really drives the
feature set that we've built
into this stuff.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
Cool.
Can we talk a little bit about
the way that you're using
YouTube APIs?
Because I see a number of
different integrations that
are being done here and some
really cool stuff.
So starting with the use of the
data APIs because I know
there are some things that are
specific to the newer version
3 of the data APIs that you all
are making use of and I
think is one of the first
companies that we've worked
with that are using things
like posting channel
bulletins, for instance.
And can you talk a little bit
more about how you're using
the data APIs?
I don't know if you're going to
be showing anything else on
screen right now.
NOAH DINKIN: Yeah.
We may want to show that
to publishing.
JEFF POSNICK: It would
be great to see
your face this time.
JONATHAN TRAVIN: A weird look.
So basically, all the data API
we are using to re-tape all
the videos, video data, you just
saw in the activity feed.
We thought we can get comments,
how many views, also
the video links so
we can supply and
creating using the terms.
So basically, the biggest part
of the API we use is to
re-tape and to show in
the activity feed.
We cache that data internally.
We use that certain that it's
more than going to be.
Not many people know it.
That make it easy for us because
as you know, when we
ask for data in YouTube, not all
the videos have this same
quantity of data,
so [INAUDIBLE]
with different specifications
on description.
So we decided to use modules so
it's easier to retrieve and
to store that data.
JEFF POSNICK: Excellent.
JONATHAN TRAVIN: We are also
using this for when creating
email campaigns.
So once you connect your account
using the YouTube host
[INAUDIBLE], we already have
permission to take this data
and to display it and use it
like a parcel of audio videos.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
JONATHAN TRAVIN: So it
simplifies the life of the
YouTube creators when they want
to create an email, they
want to see their stats, like
you just saw in one example
you call audio videos.
This was from our own account
with all of your stats, which
is very quick to see
what's going on.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
And I think this is one thing
that maybe some developers out
there don't necessarily
understand about how to use
OAuth 2.0 with their APIs.
The fact that you do go through
the approval flow
once, and once you go through
that flow, you can ask for
multiple API scopes, so I assume
you guys are asking for
both data API scopes and
also for analytics.
And then you get a token that
you can then reuse in the
background to continuously pull
data and we don't require
developers to ask users to log
in multiple times just because
they're using OAuth 2.0 So it's
great to see that you
guys are making use of that.
And I just wanted to highlight
that as something that some
developers out there who are not
as familiar with OAuth 2.0
might not understand.
So that's great.
GABRIEL SOSA: And so in the
client side, we are using the
JavaScript API of the player.
So when we are completed
integrating what you just saw,
it's a new layer over the
JavaScript API that allow us
to contribute the player in a
way that the user wanted so we
can get the integrating and then
subscribe, let's say, the
final, the watcher
to the channel.
That's another API.
So basically, we are not just
using the server-side API but
also the client-side ones,
which is really good.
And allow to play with
the YouTube player in
the way we need it.
NOAH DINKIN: Right.
I think one other one that you
alluded to is, I think we were
one of the first users
of the v3 API to do
channel bulletin posts.
And so that lets you, we already
let you push out to
Twitter and Facebook
from FanBridge.
You can type a tweet or a
post, schedule it, or
post it right now.
You can post to multiple
accounts, and then we added
YouTube in there.
So as far as we know, we were
actually the first people to
allow you to schedule
a bulletin post.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
NOAH DINKIN: Right.
So YouTube.com, you have to be
there in the moment pushing
Publish, whereas this, a channel
owner or creator can
set it up ahead of time whether
it's for late at
night, whether they're targeting
a different time
zone, over the weekend.
If they're a musician on YouTube
and they're touring,
they can set these
up ahead of time.
You can automatically include
video URLs or playlist URLs.
And just makes it really easy
to schedule this stuff ahead
of time and push out to
that channel feed.
JEFF POSNICK: And I think this
is a great feature of the API,
which I'm glad you
guys are using.
I hope more folks out there who
are watching are using it
too, because it does open up
this type of interaction that
you couldn't really do before.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Well, it's
how we can basically create a
programming infrastructure on
top of the platform so that
way as people create content,
which is really what the
content creator should focus on,
the system is able to pull
in content in real time as it's
coming out, take historic
content that we are collecting
data on as well, and now use
these tools, these APIs to
create a publishing model that
satisfies what the audience
really needs, which is almost
a continuous engagement model.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: And
that's what creates
that recurring value.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
Great.
And I see you guys are
using the YouTube
Analytics API as well.
NOAH DINKIN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
JEFF POSNICK: Because that's
kind of what opens up a lot of
this kind of advanced watch-time
metrics, and being
able to run really
granular reports.
I mean, this is actually a great
integration with the
Analytics API.
It's definitely what we had in
mind when developing it for
like doing a very targeted, I
don't say one off reports,
because you could certainly do
it on a recurring basis, but
that's really where the
API shines, I think.
So I'm glad to see this
type of integration.
NOAH DINKIN: Yeah.
I think it's showing people
stuff at the high level, which
is a lot of what YouTube's
dashboard itself does.
And then that digging in at a
granular level and crossing it
with off YouTube marketing
activities, whether it's on
other social platforms, via
email, or whatever have you
showing people the
different results
from different channels.
Because I think that's an area
that there's definitely a lot
of room to run with
on the API.
JEFF POSNICK: Great.
From a technical perspective, is
there any kind of feedback
or pain points that you want to
offer back to me on behalf
and I can pass along to our
relevant engineering folks?
We're always interested in
people's development
experience.
GABRIEL SOSA: The v3 API for
analytics was like our new
shiny toy, like a
few weeks ago.
So wanted to like play with
it and big cool features.
So we did it and like
we are waiting for
our next toy, basically.
Now, we come and talk with
plenty of API developers, and
every time we can have like a
new feature of things we try
to make use and advise
for our users.
And those two certainly can see
how leaks in FanBridge on
YouTube, and that can
get great results.
That's really nice.
The v3 API has new, good
features in terms of responses
and the data we can
get from it.
So it's really nice.
What's really the nice
times to develop.
JONATHAN TRAVIN: Yeah.
And I also want to encourage
developers to use OAuth 2.0
because you can see we really
use it like three different
APIs, we only request to the
clients only once their
credentials.
And we are fine.
We can help everyone and
they have to login
only once with YouTube.
JEFF POSNICK: And you're not
maintaining a database
somewhere with people's email
addresses and passwords or
anything like that.
I mean, this is definitely
the right way to do it.
So thank you again for
pointing that out.
JONATHAN TRAVIN: They should not
be afraid that anyone is
going just steal their password
because nobody is
saving passwords.
So there are plenty of security
things apart from our
things that I think I
would encourage any
developers to use that.
It would make their life easier
for them and for the
content creators.
JEFF POSNICK: Great.
NOAH DINKIN: What do you
guys wish the API had?
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
This is your chance.
It's not your only chance.
We obviously welcome
feedback here.
NOAH DINKIN: It's OK to be
honest even if we're on
Devloper's Live spot.
Think about pivotal.
GABRIEL SOSA: No, I think the
more data we can get on
channels and videos is the
more we can show users.
I think that with the API, we
are getting like a little bit,
but I think it is too
better to show us.
And we can make plenty
use of it.
JONATHAN TRAVIN: I like some
more real-time features.
Real time could be nice to
have for any developer.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
NOAH DINKIN: Right.
I'll throw in some other
requests on there since
they're being very
polite right now.
I think we blow through all of
our query or quota and that's
been increased.
So the ability to process much,
much larger queries or
requests whether it's batch or
not, I think that would be
super helpful.
As Jonie just said, real time
because a lot of the MCNs,
they want to know what's
trending right now across my
network, and with a two-day
delay, that's
really tough to do.
And it's not two days for every
metric, but for some of
them it is.
And I think more depth in
engagement like they said into
the subscribers.
Today, a million subscribers
is a million subscribers.
The channel doesn't know if
that's 10,000 watching
everything all day long or
a million people watching
everything once.
Right?
So more, what's an active
subscriber, just more data
around that so we can help our
clients understand that and
maybe target those people
differently.
JEFF POSNICK: All right.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: There's
also, I mean, some other parts
of the platform we're not seeing
visibility on in terms
of performance metrics
particularly around subscribe.
I think for us, that's something
where we do have an
email component to the platform
that's sometimes, I,
think helping hedge people's
bets in terms of more
customizable infrastructure
that they're
driving traffic to.
That said, we'd love be able
to export more of that into
the subscribe framework because
we do see that as
really viable kind of channel to
be marketing down into, but
there's limited degrees of
freedom right now in terms of
what platforms like us who are
building infrastructure for
these guys can see and kind of
play around with in terms of
performance of subscribe,
edit ability,
different things like that.
So little touchier, but it's
on our list of things we're
paying attention to.
JEFF POSNICK: Well that's all
excellent feedback that is now
officially on the record.
NOAH DINKIN: For better
or for worst.
JEFF POSNICK: Thank you.
We have a video of it, and so we
can present it to the folks
who make sort of
the decisions.
NOAH DINKIN: Excellent.
And we can set some timelines
on the record.
JEFF POSNICK: Yeah.
Exactly.
great.
NOAH DINKIN: We have case
studies to back it up.
JEFF POSNICK: Excellent.
So I know that we do have some
external questions that we're
being asked if your
FanBridge power.
NOAH DINKIN: FanBridge
questions.
JEFF POSNICK: Questions,
platforms.
So I'm going to pull
those up over here.
And I don't think we're going
to have time for all of them
necessarily.
But let me just reload and--
oops.
I'll give you a chance
to login on the
computer over here.
I do happen to know one
of the questions.
I'm going to short
circuit that.
And we have a question every
week as to whether YouTube
Developer Relations and Google
Developer Relations, in
general, is hiring.
So if the answer is yes and
you're interested in doing the
sort of thing that I do, working
with developers and
getting them to meet folks with
cool integrations, check
out developers.google.com/jobs.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Plus you
get to work with Jarek.
JEFF POSNICK: You do get
to work with Jarek.
Shout out to Jarek.
He's not on today's show.
NOAH DINKIN: Cool.
So we have a handful
of questions here.
So one part of the platform, I
guess someone is looking on
our site that we didn't touch
on is, we're a certified
engagement solutions
developer.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
NOAH DINKIN: So what that
enables us to do is turn on a
deeper engagement experiences
within YouTube channel pages.
So you have the Home
tab, the About tab.
Now, we can turn on
a Custom tab.
And right now, we're powering
our fan questions experience,
so you can ask a channel owner
or a creator a question, which
is what we use to solicit
these questions.
They get queued privately, and
then the creator can answer
them via text or record--
actually, this is another API
that we're using, the YouTube
Direct API I think
it's called--
to record straight from your
webcam, the answer publish it
automatically to your
YouTube channel.
JEFF POSNICK: User of it's
a webcam upload widget or
something along those lines.
NOAH DINKIN: Right.
JEFF POSNICK: I forget to use
the exact branding, but it's
great you guys are using that.
NOAH DINKIN: You can that--
JEFF POSNICK: That's
a perfect use.
NOAH DINKIN: --drop in a YouTube
video embed if you
want, if you already have
the video entered.
So that's really cool.
So that can exist right
on that tab.
And then events, right?
So whether you're a musician
touring, or you're an author
doing a book tour, or speaking
tour, or even just a TV show
using different events.
So John Mayer has this on his
channel right now his a
non-monetized channel, which
is YouTube.com/mayermusic.
And he's just announced that
he's up on tour on the Google+
Hangout two weeks ago.
And so now, we're powering all
the tour dates for that.
JEFF POSNICK: Awesome.
NOAH DINKIN: And right now,
these tabs can only be put on
non-monetized channels, but
we're crossing our fingers
that that expands.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: That
will be for our
monetized guys as well.
NOAH DINKIN: We think
that's pretty cool.
So why should a YouTube channel
collect their fan's
email addresses?
Do you want to take this one?
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Yeah.
I mean, I probably have
opinions on this.
There's something about owning
your audience that's valuable.
I think, a lot of people
approach YouTube
from the ground up.
So they're viewing it as their
entire kind of world,
particularly for
video creators.
I think more and more people
are seeing it as the social
network it really is.
And I think as you look at the
time line of social networks
that have hit the market and
growing very rapidly around
these kinds of clients, you
notice a trend that there's
really never like an Export
Your Email List button.
And so what we want to do is
have our technology both drive
growth for the channel owner
in the form of more watch
time, YouTube channel
subscribes, and so forth.
By the same time, if they can
build and own email database
as well, we do tend to see that
that is the highest ROI
channel for a lot
of these guys.
And it enables you to kind
of move traffic around.
So while we'd like to pour more
of that kind of email
tech into things like subscribe
inside YouTube
natively, we do see in lieu of
that a pretty strong demand
right now around being able to
build up and own the database
that I can then re-market
into.
And given our ability to have a
more flexible infrastructure
to work with there, it enables
us to make sure that
subscribers of that database are
having a continuous feed
of content.
Again, working with the APIs
that you guys provide to pull
in that content.
So it's a very--
so we used to call it
your email list is
your retirement fund.
I think now, for us, we
see it as really your
recurring value fund.
NOAH DINKIN: And a lot of
YouTubers sell much more and
more driving people to those web
stores, or back to YouTube
when they have a new video,
or they do a collab
with someone else.
Sometimes the platform itself
isn't the easiest place to
drive a lot of traffic, and this
gives them the ability
to, as Spencer said, point
that traffic flows
wherever they want.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Yeah.
So one kind of final pitch that
we have has also been
that the black hole metric right
now that we're noticing
kind of behind the scenes in a
lot of this, is audience turn.
So we're a SAS business that
kind of we refer to it is this
concept of basically, a turn,
people falling out.
And so I think what we're seeing
email channel really
enable people to do is drive
traffic back over onto YouTube
as the target in a way that's
a little bit more, creates
kind of a cumulative benefit, if
you will, to their videos.
So instead of seeing this
pattern of I do a video, and
it's 100,000 views, and the next
one is 150,000, and the
next one is 80,060,
then 200,000.
We can smooth out that curve
into more of a cumulative
growth curve by using channels
like email to consistently
drive traffic back and reduce,
really, that metric of turn
around your audience.
JEFF POSNICK: Sure.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: And that's
what creates true virility
because basically, turn
is negative virility.
JEFF POSNICK: OK.
That's a very interesting
way of looking at it.
Cool.
I think that's about all
the time that we
have for today's show.
And definitely want to thank
Spencer and Noah for joining
us locally here in
New York City.
And thank Jonathan and Gabriel
for joining us
on the Google+ Hangout.
I think you guys, a really
fantastic product, but also
just really cutting-edge
API integration.
So it was great to have
you guys on the show.
And we'll be back next
week at the same
time for another broadcast.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Sweet.
NOAH DINKIN: Thanks
very much, guys.
GABRIEL SOSA: Thank you.
JEFF POSNICK: All right.
Thank you.
SPENCER RICHARDSON: Cheers.
JONATHAN TRAVIN: All right.
Bye.